hello all it is time for my spoiler
review for solo a Star Wars story that
is a solid spoiler warning if you do not
want spoilers for solo a Star Wars story
probably shouldn't watch this video the
same rules apply to any of my spoiler
talks or spoiler reviews this is gonna
be a play-by-play of the entire movie
I'm just gonna talk about some things
that stood out to me well first of all I
will say if you want 100% in my opinion
on Sullivan Star Wars story I have a
spoiler free review of solo a Star Wars
story you can check that out but that's
my opinion and this particular video
this is about you this is done for you
folks out there see some people hate
solo a Star Wars story others enjoy solo
a Star Wars story or maybe people loved
some things in solo a Star Wars story
but hate the other things and vice-versa
in a world of a divided fanbase what to
do both sides are clamoring for that
camaraderie if not sex a YouTube
validation and in the world of honest
opinions being differing opinions you
can't always have that don't worry
people on both sides of got your back
today and just forewarning you this is
not the kind of video you just push play
set aside do other things do two house
chores or whatever and just listen to me
talk this is gonna require your
hands-free we're gonna have some fun
interaction today so sit back relax know
what you think about the movie and enjoy
the only solo is Star Wars story movie
review tailored for you
[Music]
solo a Star Wars story so soloist our
war story is an origin story for Han
Solo showing how he became the Han Solo
that we know and love
we have Alden Ehrenreich is Han Solo and
did you like Alden Ehrenreich spur trail
Oh Han Solo or Han Solo in general in
this movie if you did click the green
icon if you didn't click the red icon
also links are in the description and
word of advice when you're prompted to
make your choice make your choice
quickly the longer you wait the longer
I'm gonna awkwardly stand there and
waiting longer doesn't make it less
awkward you do have to pick one of them
before this video ends if it ends it's
gonna go randomly to some other thing
you're gonna be really confused